ん
6年ぐらいちょっと抜けたんですけど
いろんなことになりました
ねえ、なかなかああいう形にはならないよね
肌のゆずにね 埋まって歩いたんですよ
これが素晴らしい
これは大きな手が入り口になったんだけど
これ今大学で白いのかもで買ったんで
そのまま見てるんですけどこのまま
出てきておりました
目がすごくすごい
この絵はね砂を混ぜたりして材質を作って
危ない砂を入れて
塵をしっかり作った上で描いてますので
ちょっと不思議な材質があると思うんですよ
ただキャンバスに色んな設定になるので
マッチー存在をちゃんと作れたり
すごい
今日やる皆さんどこですか?
泊まれるんですね?
泊まれないけど
今日は日帰りです
日帰りですか?
今日の家があったんだけど
私はね
はい
あったんだけど
一人になってから
あのー
そうなんですか?
はい
今日からの方?
夜ご飯を買えるんですよ?
あーもう帰れるんですよ?
うんうんうん、素晴らしいですよ。すごいですよ。
え?そう10年目前
えーとー
お前の
バジェチを
バジェチは大学の
バセダクという大学の
魔術部だったんですよ。
毎日上手にやってました。
大学時代。
で、障害を保存だり
うん。
あのー
総合バジェチ
森の中を走るような
距離を
やったりしてました。
わーすごい。
それがもう
とても面白くて
それから馬にはまりました。
うんうん。
これは一番
何ですか?
まあ今も
たまに乗ってまって
教えながら
ちょっと馬が
あたない時とか
変わってるんですね。
はい。
うん。
してますね。